Hey youtubers it’s Charlie welcome to my
channel.
I’m such a huge fan of science fiction and
fantasy that I make videos to talk about all
my favorite fandoms with you guys.
Right now I’m making 6 to 8 videos a week
for specific fandoms including Doctor Who,
Game Of Thrones, Walking Dead, American Horror
Story, Arrow, Supernatural, Sleepy Hollow,
Agents Of SHIELD, Legend Of Korra.
I like to think of youtube as a place full
of friends you haven’t met yet and part
of the reason I make videos is to make new
fandom friends to nerd out on stuff with.
Think of it as being a less disgusting version
of Tumblr if it were run by abed from community.
I also do videos for all my favorite movie
franchises like The Hobbit, Star Wars, Marvel,
Man Of Steel and I’m even working on doing
video games in the not too distant future.
Every once in a while I partner with big networks
like BBC America for Doctor Who content.
I just got done doing a huge livestream for
the 50th Anniversary.
And I’ll be doing a bunch of awesome stuff
for the Christmas Special and Sherlock in
January.
I add new shows and movies all the time and
really like it when you guys send me new suggestions
for awesome stuff to check out.
I even give away a ton of free on a regular
basis to the most awesome of subscribers.
There’s a lot of new stuff coming this winter
and in January so be sure to subscribe to
join the conversation and get all the new
stuff.
You can also find links to all my social accounts
on my channel page.
If there’s some awesome science fiction,
fantasy or other genre fandoms that you really
want to nerd out on let me know and I’ll
add them to my list of videos to make.
Thanks so much for watching, see you guys
tonight.
High fives!